[Music]
in legally nude news hmm
submitted by nine oh two one oh Nikki
hey Nikki fun bye Bella he'll lick you
from Beverly Hills I don't know a man
who does his yard work naked is pissing
off the neighbors he's at the backyard
in the front yard front dangerous
exposure can you imagine this fool like
[ __ ] he's picking the larboard and
all the grass is slapping his dick oh oh
what if he's picking out weeds he's
bending over and over and the [ __ ]
sack
he doesn't even crouch like Asians squat
when he picks the weed he bends over a
fool he doesn't he hasn't break at the
knees well just the perspective he's
like you know hosing the garden and the
water just spouting from Mikey yeah yeah
yeah this dude according to Florida law
all of would be Florida come on you guys
you actually okay if we're not on the
sidewalk exactly
he's on his property so he can whip out
his penis and show the world if he wants
as long as he's not touching it
inappropriately oh so he's just an like
a like a nudist
yeah this family's a nudist and so the
neighbors have been calling the cops and
complaining because this dude likes to
do his yard work he likes to wash his
car he likes he likes to just fix up his
house his little soaps I'm within the
legal parameters it is damn I salute
this guy and then to one of the
neighbors was like yeah he just like I
step out of my house and the first thing
I see is my neighbor bent over grabbing
his dick hanging out but no it was like
his old ass and everything cuz he was
bent over she was like yeah you know he
should be thinking about the children in
the neighborhood cuz there's a bus stop
nearby what's wrong with that people are
uncomfortable with nudity the don't look
over there exactly that's what the cops
are telling the neighbors yeah
if it's like the naked guys house then
you kind of like go whoa [ __ ] it that's
the naked guy how it is but like what if
you want to take in your [ __ ] senior
you don't I mean like ah you know what I
mean well you know that's how I feel
freedom with I when I go on hikes right
like in Eaton Canyon and as I'm trying
to take in the nature and then I see
like some graffiti on a rock exactly but
I just got what they got to do what they
got to do this I just look over here
beauty on the rock yes I just keep
walking they're gonna do what they're
gonna do like you're just writing
graffiti is all wrong yeah yeah so I'm
just like notorious this guy is within
his legal parameters though it's also
kind of like a man you just work in the
system yep
yeah so somebody is down to watch the
system especially if it's in his
family's hair what did you start some
movement now everyone can walk out free
be naked that's even better
I think we're also not looking at it
like this cause back in the day like
your neighborhood meant something you
know I mean like admit a sense of
community like you know your neighbor to
the left you know your neighbor to the
right like if you go out of town hey Bob
I'm gonna be heading out yeah we got you
know we got eyes on your house or
whatever but like now there's like none
of that well back in the day people were
allowed to be naked yeah you know it's
also part of that accepting your
neighbor and knowing the differences cuz
I grew up in a neighborhood like that
yeah and my mom was always asking me why
the Lebanese neighbor's house smells
like [ __ ] and I'm like it's just what
they cook probably for who cares let's
go over there and have dinner and I was
still we're still really accepting even
though we're all different on the street
yeah that's funny cuz Bart is the naked
neighbor everywhere everywhere we go do
you think it'd be better if he painted a
butterfly on a stick no it's part of the
name if his dick was part of nature
right so when he's walking around it
just looks like a butterfly is there
look like Free Willy does it be a killer
whale
that is it okay I don't know no how old
is this guy I don't know I don't know
his age I feel like there's one rule for
public space and one rule for private
space so like the public space is
technically he's not violate late
he's not violating the law but there is
a social contract to you like this
public space whatever can be in your eye
that you can't escape from or like you
know if it if your actions might
conflict and hurt someone else's beliefs
or their lifestyle or whatever then I
feel like that's kind of overstepping
boundaries morally or maybe ethically or
maybe you know just socially yeah yeah
it's not really like illegal but you are
gonna cause friction by doing what
you're gonna do cuz I see it as a little
bit selfish yeah that's I'm seeing the
sense of community oh yeah but why not
from his perspective he's not your
[ __ ] clothes were hurting my eyes you
need to get your ass naked but he's not
the majority he's like I'll put on
clothes today you take your clothes off
cuz then so for me I'm with you where
I'm like [ __ ] he can do his own thing
as long as he's not coming into my space
like I wouldn't I wouldn't care yeah um
but then I'm thinking [ __ ] I don't want
to explain it to Tiger like what the
hell's going on with this guy you know I
should write that so I can show that the
world is weird
and then so he's already grown up I
think I think just living in this world
you know that they're weird is that he
already has a weird yeah and weird [ __ ]
you know a lot of people you know that
grow up in the bubble and they don't
really know it's weird the world there's
a lot of people that have no [ __ ]
clue I agree to that but I don't think
we would be those people that would
raise our child in a bubble but it helps
out if your neighbors even weirder it
accelerates the process yeah I guess I
really wouldn't mind a naked neighbor
because I'm not afraid of nudity that
much and I think it's funny but I guess
like if I put myself in my conservative
mom's shoes she would probably be like
uncomfortable with it oh for sure but I
would like I would actually want this
because it's funny
I want I could tell so many people I'm
very like if you you had the notorious
naked neighbor man in your view I call
the sack yeah like honestly people
probably come over and just people watch
like you probably just sit on the lawn
buddy here and just try to see the next
funny position this guy's about to be
you I think that's a good idea for their
neighbors yeah like can you imagine like
you just got in a fight and you're
storming out the house [ __ ] - Bob
what is picking weeds and shape it's
such a what if he's standing yes it's
like watching his car just like wet at
the car wash I don't know man it's it
was funny because this music like the
media they were trying to interview him
but he declined to comment stating that
he and his family are very private
people do something that causes all this
attraction but like attention but then
you know what that actually makes a
little bit of sense because I can see
people that because I think if they
think they're just an animal so they're
like ok this is my skin this is what's
supposed to be shown on the outside to
to nature right so I'm not private with
my body parts but I'm private with my
thoughts yeah and I can kind of
understand like with it yeah I mean it's
a mentality right like I'm on the inside
so I'm gonna keep my thoughts in here
but this is meant to be on the outside
so forth for people to see like how he
thinks is like is like seeing him naked
he's like having people will be a part
of his inner life again I'm thinking
like also in the next coming weeks the
neighbors are gonna try to talk to him
and see what they could come up with
some sort of solution that makes
everyone happy which I'm thinking it
would be like a fence like just put up a
fence he could be like did you just put
up cameras in like Truman shows ass and
just like have like live streams all the
time and stuff like that so it's like yo
you got
he's filled their foot but if their do
if they're doing that on their own
property and the general vicinity of
perspective happens to be this and you
happen to come out actually I don't know
if you can record directly into
someone's yard without their keys nobody
saying if the vicinity was cuz I caught
up with a wife might have to but the
cutoff might have to be your property oh
but I wonder how long until someone says
they saw him jacking off or they saw him
touching himself in Oh like my that's
the only reason why it's legal right
it's cuz he's not doing anything weird
that's what I don't get is like why
doesn't he move to like a nudist colony
or like a group cuz maybe he's like why
should I have to I love it here they
should tempt him like one day when he's
like naked on his lawn they should put
like you know like hundred-dollar bills
on the sidewalk right in front of his
house cuz if he like just cross that
mine boom yeah you're just like across
the way with the little of thread you
know those like trucks with the stripper
advertisements they have the TV yeah I
would pull up and just play porn so he
has a boner you could be like hey
inappropriate dick because if it's lit
the whole time he's full-on erect a
boner I like that's grounds for
something yeah it's gotta be I don't
know that's a bodily function but I
don't know because like bodily choice to
keep that function away from like yet
it's it's a [ __ ] loaded weapon is
what it is legal because he wasn't
inappropriately touching himself so
about movies program if you think about
movies though it's like they show dick
but it's always limp you know even if
it's like r-rated or whatever they don't
show a throbbing hard veiny ass dick
visual for the same reason they don't
show like vaginas outside of like a bush
yeah I mean never details yeah I don't
know it's just porn at that point
softcore maybe because if this fool was
walking around with a hard-ass dick and
he's [ __ ] washing his car he has a
little baby sponge on his [ __ ] dick
too and he's using that [ __ ] he's doing
that you know like he's doing yard work
he's pushing the [ __ ] lawn mower has
a hard-ass dick I'm pretty sure the
neighbors he wouldn't be they would not
be okay well he's got a hard dick but
it's like holding a bucket of like seeds
and these like planting me oh it's like
a helper yeah about it like that
damn that's kind of creative you like
trimming the [ __ ] hedges and [ __ ] and
it catches into the bucket or like like
hummingbirds are like feeding coming
Birds like a seed basket who has a
flower basket and he's like doing
gardening and he's collecting flowers
hold it up by a dick and all snow-white
and [ __ ] yeah that's a pretty good usage
for taking everything like skew thing
you can think of to be on dry reroofing
in [ __ ] his skin is solar-powered so
he's got to just collect energy many
uses of a dick
[Music]
[Music]